[Music]
turning to the coronavirus tonight as
the omicron variant continues to spread
people across the valley are scrambling
to find testing today the southern
nevada health district announced the
highest number of coveted 19 cases
reported in a single day since the
beginning of the pandemic madison
kimbrough is live from sam boyd stadium
tonight the newest covid 19 drive-thru
testing site that's opening tomorrow
madison
yeah so this site opens tomorrow but for
many finding a free coven 19 testing
site across the valley has been a real
struggle and for many they're left
wondering if they have the flu or if
they in fact have contracted the coven
19 virus
it sure seems like someone should have
been prepared for this
we knew that omicron was spreading two
months ago now people across the valley
are frustrated over the lack of free
testing options when my co-workers
struggled three days just to find a
place they ended up getting in but we're
still waiting for her results pretty
frustrating the southern nevada health
district announcing the highest number
of coven 19 cases reported in a single
day since the beginning of the pandemic
as of friday there have been 392
971 cases of covet 19 reported in clark
county with an increase of over 6 000
cases from the previous day in addition
the health district is reporting 15
deaths one woman who arrived in line
early at the ymca centennial hills
location says she was turned away 30
minutes later after being told that they
ran out of tests my frustration is
not even open one hour and they ran out
of tests
surely these people had to have some
common sense that more than 30 people
were going to want this task as for free
coven 19 testing elsewhere appointments
need to be booked a week in advance and
for many the waiting game isn't soon
enough it would be good to know am i
fighting cova or do i just have the blue
or just a bad code i'm taking
over-the-counter medicines and a variety
of stuff
you know but i'm not getting better
this site at sam boyd stadium opens
tomorrow from 5 30 to 10 30 p.m this
site will take the place of unlv's
paradise location with a bigger venue to
house more cars and create less traffic
now we'll have a full list of tests and
vaccination sites up on our website so
you can check that out at 8newsnow.com
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now